حسنًا ،
الجميع مرعوبون من العنف
بغض النظر عن الجانب الذي أنت فيه ، إنه أمر
فظيع ولكن
أم أنه
مجرد تذكير بمدى
الكراهية على كلا الجانبين
أحيانًا ومن الصعب ألا نشعر
بالمسؤولية أحيانًا عن جزء منه ،
فالطريقة التي
نتصرف بها كدولة تحرض أحيانًا على الكثير
من الكراهية على الجانب الآخر ولا يمكنني أن
أعرف أنه لا يمكنني إلقاء اللوم عليهم على الرغم من أنني
لا أعتقد أن العنف سيكون حلًا مؤكدًا في بعض الأحيان. أعتقد أن هذا ما يؤمنون به وهذا هو
السبب في أنهم
يتصرفون
بالطريقة
التي يفعلون بها ، إنه لأمر مروع أن يفقد الناس من كلا
الجانبين
حياتهم بسبب هذا ولكن آه
أنت تعلم أنني أشعر بالمسؤولية الكبيرة عن
الأشياء التي نقوم بها في بلدنا في
حكومتنا ، ليس لأنني أستطيع اتخاذ
القرارات ولكني آمل أن أكون مسؤولاً
أجنبيًا